Another aspect of particularly primate reproduction is that we have invasive
placentas.
Let's take a look at what that means.
Yeah.
Implantation of the embryo is aggressive.
It's invasive and this invasiveness is actually ancient,
but it was lost in some lineages.
Okay.
The degree of invasiveness varies among mammalian groups.
Invasion is something that should give a fitness advantage early in life because
it gives the embryo increased control over nutrition and growth.
Yeah.
However,
there are tradeoffs.
Greater embryonic control over maternal blood pressure increases the risk of
Preeclampsia and animals with more invasive placentas have greater risk of
metastatic cancer.
So the fact that placentas are invasive really has a number of rather surprising
consequences.
One is it shows that the embryo and the mother are to a certain degree in
conflict with each other and the embryo is trying to take more control over the
mother.
Then the mother would like to give and as with many other things that we've seen
every time a system comes in that has a big advantage,
that also means that evolution is willing to tolerate a big vulnerability or a
big cost in order to get that advantage.
And in this case,
the diseases of pregnancy and the risk of medicine.
Metastatic cancer are two of the costs are vulnerabilities that are associated
with invasive placentas.
Yeah.
So the pre embryo is implanting aggressively the outer embryonic cells,
the trophoblasts actually bore into the uterus by succeeding enzymes that
dissolve the tissue that protects maternal blood,
blood vessels.
Yeah.
The endometrium is both enabling and limiting this invasion.
So there is an overlap of interest between the embryo and the mother of course,
but there is also some conflict of interest.
Okay.
The trophoblast then becomes part of the placenta where it secretes hormones
that can mimic maternal hormones and these hormones influence maternal blood
sugar and the dilation of maternal arteries in the placenta.
That helps to regulate the delivery of nutrients to the embryo.
The degree of invasion and the ability of embryonic tissue to control nutrient
flow depend on placental morphology and that varies among major groups of
mammals.
So one of the things we're going to be looking at is the variation in placental
morphology.
Now for our purposes,
the critical feature of placental morphology or the ones that determine how many
layers of cell and tissue separate fetal blood from maternal blood and how
intimately fetal and maternal tissue are intertwined.
How large surface area
prior to placenta formation,
there are six layers of tissue that separate maternal and fetal blood during
class contagion.
One,
two or three of the maternal layers can be lost
and the shape of the placenta can be either diffuse.
That means that occupies most of the surface of the embryonic sack.
It can be cuddled lead canary with multiple discrete attachments.
They can be zoned [inaudible] forming a band around the fetus or it can be
discoid attaching at one point and being smaller than the fetus.
We have discoid Placentas,
so here are the potential fetal and maternal layers.
On the left we have fetal tissue.
On the right we have maternal tissue.
This is a fetal blood vessel.
This is a maternal blood vessel.
The blood vessel is surrounded by an endothelium.
That's layer one.
Then there is connective tissue and then there are the chorionic epethelial
cells as the,
when the Zygote or the pre embryo first implants.
This would be the layer cells lying next to the endometrium.
Those are the endometrial epithelial cells.
Then there's maternal connective tissue than there are maternal endothelial
cells surrounding the blood vessel.
And then there is the delivery of blood itself.
So potentially three fetal and three maternal layers.
The fetal extra embryonic membranes all go into forming the placenta and both
fetal and maternal tissue layers can contribute to the structure of the blood
vessels to connective tissue and epithelial cells can contribute to the
placenta.
So placental classification based on cell layers has these names.
Epithelium Chorio,
which is cows,
pigs and horses is the full set of six membranes in endothelial Chorio,
which would be caught dogs and cats,
one layer of maternal tissue.
The uh,
epithelial layer in the endometrium has been lost.
However,
in Hema Correale,
which characterizes,
uh,
humans and rodents,
the growing chorionic Villi erode through the maternal endothelium.
They form a Hema Correale placenta in which the fetal chorionic epithelium is
bathed directly in maternal blood.
So here is the fetal fetal epithelium here is actually in Ville I,
this is just a simplified cross section and the maternal blood is actually right
up against it.
So it's bathed in maternal blood.
So when and why did that evolve and what are the consequences?
Well,
here is the evolutionary history of layers laid out in a phylogenetic tree.
And what we're looking at are in black,
we have epithelium,
Choreo and red endothelial Correale and in blue hemo Correale and we,
what we can see is the Hema Correale placenta is actually ancient.
That's not a derived condition.
That is an ancient condition.
Interestingly,
that condition has been lost in certain groups.
So for example,
in things like the,
we don't really know what the condition was in a deeper ancestor than that,
but in the marsupials they have an empathy Leo Correale Placenta.
So they have the full six layers and that is also the case in the ungulates.
So things like pigs and horses and cows and hippopotamuses,
they all have epithelial Correale placentas.
Then the endothelial Correale.
So the one where one tissue layer has been lost on the maternal side includes
things like elephants and aardvarks and malls,
European malls and foxes and cats and,
and uh,
fruit bats.
Also,
uh,
another set of bets.
However,
humans retain the ancient condition,
so they have a hemo Correale placenta.
The fewer the layers,
the shorter the gestation time.
So if we looked at 109 species of all memo orders,
then the fewer the number of tissue layers that separate maternal and fetal
blood,
the shorter that gestation length through given maternal body mass.
So the shift from the noninvasive epithelial Correale placenta to the
intermediate really invasive endothelial Correale placenta to the highly
invasive Hema Correale placenta reduces gestation time by 35 days.
It might be more accurate to turn that around and say since the Hema Correale
placenta is the ancestral condition,
that adding tissue layers increased gestation time by 35 days.
This is what some of the macro morphology placenta this looks like.
So here we have a diffuse placenta.
It's characteristic of horses and pigs.
The cost of lead Neri Placenta is characteristic of cows.
The zone re placenta,
which actually wraps around the amniotic sac is characteristic of carnivores and
elephants.
So dogs,
cat seals,
bears and elephants.
And the discoid placenta is characteristic of primates and rodents.
So we have that kind of placenta and sodas.
A mouse here,
the light pink is the amniotic sac and the dark pink is the placenta.
These shapes also have an evolutionary history.
It turns out that our discoid placenta,
which is here in black,
is also ancient and primitive and the derived forms are things like the diffuse
placenta found in pigs.
The cuddle lead,
Neri Placenta found in a cow.
The Baidus discoid placenta,
which is found in tree shrews is uh,
two sets of disks and the Zona re placenta,
which wraps around the amniotic sac is found in foxes,
cats.
And then in some of the Afro Therians,
the elephant,
the Aardvark,
the rock hyrax and so forth.
However,
our discoid placenta is ancient and primitive.
Yeah.
However,
what about Vli?
The internal morphology of the Placenta so it can be folded lamellar villas,
trabecular labyrinthine,
the villas Nate,
part of our placenta,
which you can see sketched here.
So this is,
uh,
where the actual interface is.
And the,
uh,
fetal epithelium is bathed here in maternal blood.
So with an extensive surface area,
which is,
uh,
created by making a treelike villas that is protruding into that space that is
derived in humans.
Okay.
And it's also shared with,
uh,
some of the carnivores.
Okay?
So if we take all of the differences in human plantation and we compare them
with nonhuman primates and other placental mammals,
what we see is that primary interstitial implantation is something that only
occurs,
uh,
in great apes among primates.
And if we look among other placental animals,
we can find it in Guinea pigs and a few other roads.
The other thing here in this table,
I would like to emphasize is that have to do with deep trophoblast invasion that
reaches the third,
uh,
the inner third of the myometrium.
So this is something shared only with great apes,
uh,
among primates.
And if we look among other mammals,
we can see it with even deeper invasion in some bats and in the Guinea pig.
So what that means is that the great ape share the risk of Preeclampsia with us
because this deep invasions seems to be a morphological precondition for that
risk.
And most Rodens and Armadillos do not.
Now what about vulnerability?
Well,
there are striking similarities between invasive placental cells and invasive
cancer cells.
The cellular mechanisms that stem cells use to invade the Placenta may be reused
by cancer cells to invade in spread during metastases.
This involves cell adhesion molecules,
the extracellular matrix and metallo protein aces that are in the context of
extracellular matrix.
Angiogenesis is also a feature of both implantation and cancer spread.
We now know at least 11 genes that are expressed,
both informal trophoblastic tissue and in malignant tumors.
So understanding the maternal mechanisms that control trophoblast invasion may
help us to improve methods of controlling metastases.
Yeah,
a comparative study showed that animals that have less invasive presentation
have less risk of metastatic cancer.
So here we have four panels for four different kinds of cancer.
The
bars on the x axis are basically cows,
horses,
cats and dogs.
The x axis is percentage of malignant tumors and this is for skin cancer,
glandular epithelium,
non glandular epithelium and connective tissue.
And the pattern that we see basically is that for three out of four of these
cancer types,
skin glandular epithelium and connective tissue,
the risk of metastatic cancer is much higher in the groups that have invasive
placentation and much lower in those that do not have invasive presentation.
So cows and horses are at less risk of metastatic cancer than our dogs and cats.
To summarize,
Mammalian placentas very widely in the number of tissue layers that separate the
fetal and maternal blood in the shape of the structures that mediate the
exchange and in the degree of fetal invasion of maternal tissue.
Human placentas are a mixture of ancient and derived features.
Deep invasion is derived,
we share it with chimpanzees and gorillas and it is associated with the risk of
Preeclampsia of high maternal,
dangerously high maternal blood pressure during pregnancy.
Trophoblast invasion,
pre adept cells for metastases.
It isn't early life fitness benefit that's trading off with elite light late
life risk.
So it's a very good example of antagonistic plant ropey
animals that have less invasive presentation have less risk of metastatic
cancer.